>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Chang-rae Lee immigrated to
United States from Korea in 1965
when he was just three years old.
He attended some of the country's
most prestigious schools -
Phillips Exeter Academy
and Yale, earned an MFA.
And then like most aspiring writers,
he became a financial
analyst on Wall Street.
[ Laughter ]
>> That, fortunately, did not last
long, and soon he turned to fiction.
His novels immediately
attracted wide critical praise.
"Native speaker" and "A
Gesture Life" are searching
and powerful stories about
the special challenges
of immigrant life, the fragility of
identity and the burdens of memory.
His work can be dark and
very serious as we've seen
in his new novel "The Surrendered"
or even comic and poignant as we saw
in his previous novel, "Aloft."
Now, a professor of Creative
Writing at Princeton University,
Chang-rae Lee is a novelist
who reminds us not only
that we're a country of
immigrants, but that the process
of immigration is always
more fraught
and more complex than we imagined.
Please join in welcoming him.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi!
>> You know, it seems
like I can never run away
from that one brief
year on Wall Street.
[ Laughter ]
>> I worked literally 365 days to
the day, and I quit on that day,
so I could say to my father I worked
a year and I'm gonna quit now.
But sometimes I see I get e-mails
from friends and acquaintances
from that time, and you
know, they always say, "Oh,
it's great that you've started
writing books and da-da-da."
And you know, but they
always, of course say,
but you would have
made a lot of money.
[ Laughter ]
>> You know, I'd like
to have a two more zeros
in my account, but that's okay.
I was just gonna talk a little
bit about "The Surrendered,"
a book that came out
in the late spring.
It's a book that I've been thinking
about writing for a long time.
And I guess I'll just say a
few words, and I hope that's--
I hope that you people will ask
questions 'cause I much rather
respond to questions
that you might have.
But one of the questions I
always get is about, you know,
where stories come from for writers.
People are always curious.
Even people who know me well,
you know, sometimes look at me,
and think, "Why did you write that
book and where did that come from.
You know, what's wrong with you?"
Or, you know, what's--
why that obsession.
And there are lots of reasons.
You know, sometimes, it's stuff
that I've been thinking
about for a long time.
Sometimes it's an accident.
You know, my second novel, I
read an article in the newspaper
about Korean comfort
women and I decided, "Boy,
I can't believe I don't know about
this, so I'm gonna look into it,"
and thus a novel came to be.
But this particular novel, I was--
I've been thinking about
writing it for a long, long time.
It's a novel that takes place
partly during the Korean War.
Its main character meet during the
Korean War and it follows their--
their relationships and their
struggles after the war.
It's really a postwar novel
rather than a war novel.
But it's a book that, obviously,
I'm Korean-American, and I'd thought
about writing a book about that
time for a long time, you know,
ever since I became sort of,
I guess, a writer in earnest.
I guess I'm still a
writer in earnest.
And obviously, it's my background
that, you know, that spurred me on,
and particularly my father and my
mother's experience during the war.
This was 1950s, so they
were young, you know,
young kids about 11
and 12 years old.
They never talked about their
experience during the war.
A lot of people, you know, of their
generation never wanted to talk
about the war and still never
want to talk about the war.
So, it's something that
I didn't know about.
You know, writers often write
to fill in their questions,
to you know, to satisfy
some curiosity
about a particular subject.
And it was particularly
something that was, you know,
important in my life
back in college.
I was taking a Korean history class,
Modern Korean History class seminar.
And for that seminar, I had to
write something about my family,
kinda autobiographical piece.
And I ended up kinda cornering
my father and asking him
about his experience during the war.
His family, just for a quick
background, was from Pyongyang
which is now the capital
of North Korea.
And on the eve of hostilities, like
many thousands of other refugees,
they had started to move southward
to escape the fighting
and to get to the south.
So he told me a little
bit about that time.
That was the first time
we'd ever talked about it.
I was just kinda idly
writing notes, you know,
not really thinking
about what I might hear.
He got into this story of how
they moved southward, you know,
on foot, sometimes on trucks.
And on this one particular night,
that he focused on by a train.
And if you think about it, it was
a car along many cars of train,
you know, many train cars all
put together moving very slowly
through dark countryside.
He was actually on top of the train
because there was no
room inside the trains.
These are, you know, cargo
cars not resident, you know,
not passenger cars as we know them.
So he and his family,
and particularly he
and his brother were
on top of this train.
They kinda balanced on top
with lots of other refugees.
It turns out, of course my
research that I found out,
that this was often the case.
And one night as they're
chandelling along at this low speed,
the train hit something
way up ahead, it lurched,
and his younger brother
who was about eight
or nine years old fell
off in between the cars.
And unfortunately,
his leg was amputated.
And my father jumped out.
And unfortunately, his
brother died of blood loss.
It was an amazing story to hear.
And my father really, you
know, probably devoted
about five sentences to it.
You know, it's amazing to me to
think of my father, someone who'd,
you know, he's-- my father is a
psychiatrist, very mild mannered
and someone who'd never, you
know, none of his actions
or things we talked about,
the way he conducted his life
whatever portray that something
like this had happened to him,
which I taught was amazing.
But of course, that
story stayed with me.
And for many years, I
thought, you know, I--
that would maybe be
some kind of lynchpin
or something for a longer story.
So, I started this particular
novel about five years ago,
not writing about my
father but writing
about three other characters -
one character in particular a young
girl, a Korean girl named June,
who at the start of this
book, begins a journey
as my father did with
her twin siblings.
It's-- you know, again, as I
mentioned, my father only described,
you know, just a few things
on that trip, so obviously,
I had to reinvent everything
and elaborate
to a great extent everything
that happens in this book.
And of course, as all books are, you
bended tales and you create things
for the purpose of the
book, not so much worrying
about what happens in real life.
So, this is a book that in some ways
was galvanized by that experience.
And that experience
was the spark of it.
So, I'll just-- what I'd thought I'd
do is I'll just read the first page
or two about it just
to give you a sense
of how it sounds 'cause I
believed that prose should sound
like something that the
writer wants it to sound like,
it's not just about storytelling,
it's not just about
showing you what's happen.
And then I'd love to hear some,
you know, questions from you
about really anything you'd like.
Korea, 1950.
The journey was nearly over.
The night was unusually chilly,
the wind sharpened by the speed
of the train as it rolled southward
through the darkened valley.
The cotton blanket June had stolen
was large enough to spread as a tarp
and at the same time wrap around
her younger brother and sister
and herself, but it was threadbare
and for brief stretches
the train would accelerate
and the wind would cut
right through to them.
It had not been a problem the night
before but now they were riding
on top of the boxcar, as there was
no more room within any of them,
even as the train was more
than a dozen cars long.
A massive phalanx of refugees had
met the train at the last station,
and in the time it took her siblings
to relieve themselves by the side
of the tracks they had lost
their place and had had
to climb the rusted ladder between
the cars, June running alongside
for fifty meters until her brother
was high enough on the rungs
so she herself could jump up and on.
There was a score or so
of people atop every car,
groupings of families and
neighbors, mostly women and the old
and the young, and then a
cluster or two like theirs,
children traveling by themselves.
June was eleven; Hee-Soo and
Ji-Young had just turned seven.
They were fraternal twins, though
looked as much alike as a sister
and brother could, only the cut
of their hair distinguishing them.
>> June knew they could have
waited in the hope of another train
with room inside but
it hadn't been cold
when they stopped just before
dusk and she decided they ought
to keep moving while
they had the chance.
To keep moving was always safer
than lingering in one place,
and there was nothing back
at the depot to eat, anyway.
There were a few scruffy soldiers
drinking and playing cards
by the depot shack, though their
presence could only mean trouble,
even for a girl her age.
She was tall besides and she was
wary of soldiers and any stray men.
They were some two hundred
kilometers south of Seoul,
past Chongju, and June
was now thinking
that they would make
their way down to Pusan,
where her uncle's family lived,
though she didn't know whether they
were still there, or even alive.
The train sped up on a slight
decline and June curled her arm
around her siblings,
spooning them tightly.
They lay as low as they
could between the ridges
of the steel roof of the boxcar.
They were on the front
end of the car and as
such they were fully
buffeted by the rushing wind.
They were fortunate
to have a blanket;
many others on top
of the cars did not.
It was too early to sleep but
it was cold and it was better
for the twins not to be
active, especially given
that the two had shared only a
few crackers early in the day.
June herself had eaten nothing.
They had eaten well the day
before, as June had found,
below a footbridge, a GI's
abandoned pack of canned rations,
a small bar of chocolate,
and a sleeve of crackers.
Her brother and sister were
so hungry that they'd bolted
down the chocolate first as
June was smashing the cans open
against a rock.
She'd cut her finger and gotten some
blood on the food but they ate it
without hesitation, two tins of
stewed beef and one of sardines
in tomato sauce, afterward each
taking a turn to lick the insides,
carefully, with the
deftness of cats.
She made them save the crackers.
They'd been by themselves on
the road since their mother
and older sister were killed two
weeks before, at first traveling
with some people from their
town but then blending
in with the endless stream of other
refugees moving southward along the
pushed-up roads and
embankments of the river valleys.
At another time it might
have been a pretty journey,
the hills just turning the colors
of pumpkin and hay and pomegranate
and the skies depthless and clear,
but now everywhere one looked most
of the trees had been felled for
fuel and there was only a hazy,
oppressive brightness refracted
from the shorn hillsides.
There were formerly cultivated
fields of potatoes and cabbages,
and then the terraces of rice
paddies, but all had been stripped
and then abandoned during
these first months of the war.
I'll stop there thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> As I said, the first
chapter then goes on
and we follow the lives
of the other characters.
But enough about me and this book,
I hope that someone of
you have a question.
Sir?
>> Hi, could you please
talk a little bit
about your writing process
and your daily routines
when you're working on a manuscript?
>> Yeah, my writing process
is a very ordinary one.
I really treat it like a job.
You know, I have young girls, 9
and 13, and so, I mean, you know,
I help get them together for school.
I make breakfast.
One of us will take them out to
the bus and then at about 8:30
or 8 o'clock or so I sit at
my desk and work 'till lunch.
And lunch, as I said, with
someone else is very important.
If I don't know that I'm
going to have a good lunch
or I don't know what's
gonna be there for lunch,
I have a lot of trouble
writing actually.
[Laughter] So, I-- that's sort
of my, the beacon, you know,
it's pinging at the end
of that long morning.
And then after lunch, you know, you
have a little bit of lunch coma.
[ Laughter ]
>> So I rest a little bit, maybe
listen to some music, read,
and then work a couple of hours
until the girls come
home, and then it's over.
But it's a, you know,
I'm a very slow writer.
I don't know why that is, I wish
I could be like some other writers
who could just toss off a
thousand words in the morning or
and like them but I just can't do
that, so it's pretty painstaking.
And I must say it's difficult
work, it's very difficult work.
And I always distrust people
who say it's not difficult work
especially my students who say that.
Yes?
>> I saw that you are
an English major.
And with your story of your father,
I wonder if he approved of that.
And when did you first know that
you wanted to be a writer as a way
of making your living, and
when did you started thinking
of yourself really as a writer?
>> Well, I don't-- it took me
a long time to think of really
to accept the fact that this
is really what I wanna do
for a living, you know.
And obviously, I quit
my job because I thought
that I should give myself
a chance at doing so.
But well before that in
high school, you know,
I had some great English teachers
and I always love books,
I always love reading.
I hang out with the
library a lot as a kid.
And you know, if you are someone
who's, you know, who loves to read,
at some point, I think you wonder,
well, could I give this experience
to someone else, you know, could
I crop this language and story,
create these characters,
and you just wonder that.
And you know I started
doing a little bit of that
in high school and
really enjoying it.
But you know, part of my background,
because my folks are, you know,
we're all immigrants and we didn't
really have a safety net gear,
we didn't have any other relatives.
And you know my parents sent me
into these nice expensive schools,
I never thought that it would
actually be something I did
for a living.
And it, you know, it wasn't, you
know, my parents didn't come here
to have their son become
an artist or writer, right.
It's honorable, but it obviously
it's not something that's bankable.
So, I think it took me just a
long time to just abuse myself
for that notion that, you
know, that I could do this and
or that I could-- I should try
to honor what I really
did want to do, yeah.
>> So, when did you actually really
think of yourself as a writer?
>> Probably after my
first novel is published.
And then I thought, you know, and
regardless of what people thought
of it, I thought, you
know, I did absolutely--
I didn't enjoy the process
because as I said writing
is sometimes tortuous,
but I got a lot of, you know, that
sense of fulfillment out of that.
Yeah.
>> I was wondering, I'm an
International Studies major,
and a lot of times Korean-Americans
are referred to as a model minority,
and that they go to grade
schools like Yale and then--
>> It does for no good, though--
>> -- such as yourself.
[ Laughter ]
>> And I was wondering about perhaps
maybe Korean nationals would look
at your life and feel
envious or seem--
I mean it seems like
you've time and articulate,
that you've had this
really ideal life.
And I'm wondering how they
feel about you writing
about this incredible suffering,
just like Korean national suffering.
>> Well, I don't know yet.
The book has not appeared
in Korea yet, this book,
so I don't know yet how they feel.
But you know, I think
it's a myth too.
I mean I think a lot of
Korean-Americans and I know
that 'cause I get lots of
notices from philanthropic groups
about Korean-Americans were
struggling, and you know.
So, I think that's a myth about
Korean-American's doing so well
and all of us doing so well.
And then of course, you know,
it's, like anything else,
you know, everyone's different.
And what seems well, like
that someone is doing well
in the outside might actually
not be, you know, so great, so.
>> Nationals would be receptive to
an American telling their story--
>> I don't know.
Maybe. I don't know, I hope so.
>> Thank you.
>> Anyong-haseyo.
Would you compare or how would
you compare your fiction with that
of Richard Kim who wrote "The
Martyred" and "The Innocent"?
>> Well, you know, those
are wonderful novels.
I think my fiction is perhaps more
interested in its own language more
than Mr. Kim's books were.
He's the beauty of his
language, is a kind of spareness.
And it's often a directness
that is kind of startling,
and I think that's what's
wonderful about his writing.
I think my books, in this book maybe
less so than my previous three tend
to be a little conscious of
their own storytelling modes.
So, I think they much more
are about their own language
and also just strictly
and discreetly that story.
>> Hi. Can you tell me who
your favorite writers are
and how they may have helped
you find your own writing voice?
>> I have so many favorite writers.
You know, I-- but when-- I suppose
I could mention a few when I was say
in 7th and 8th and 9th grade,
you know, when I was really--
and maybe there are
more particularly books
than anything else, and I mentioned
those a couple minutes ago.
You know, James Joyce's collection,
the Dubliners I thought was
such a beautiful collection and
I didn't-- up until that point,
I hadn't had a real
sensitivity to language
in a prose fiction than I did then.
Some of the Ernest Hemingway's
stories particularly some of his
in the collection "In Our Time",
the little vignettes of wartime,
and I thought those are really
harrowing in, but you know,
they had a beautiful spark to them.
So those are some writers that--
you know, I'd always been attracted
to writers that, you know,
when you're reading them
or you're reading a particular
work where you feel it's almost not
that you're not even holding
a book anymore, you know,
that something has-- something else
has happened that you have this,
you know, very corporal
bodily somatic experience.
And all the intellectual
stuff is there.
All the symbolic and
spiritual stuff is there.
But ultimately, it's a physical
thing, because you know,
'cause it's an emotional thing.
And those are certain moments
that, yeah, that I felt that.
>> How are you?
>> Great.
>> You mentioned before you
worked with the writing on
and researching the comfort
women, and I used to live in Seoul
where I was involved in the
Reparations Movement on behalf
of the comfort women, and I think
it's really a powerful issue.
And I was wondering if you
could speak to your role
in either researching or using
writing as a tool of empowerment
on behalf of women who
experienced sexual slavery.
>> Well, I-- for that book,
that book novel is called
"A Gesture Life," and I did do
a lot of research for that book.
And one of the great
moments of research
in my writing experience has been--
was going over to Seoul and
meeting with, I would say,
about a dozen of the women survivors
who were living in a house together
and the house was donated to
them by some Buddhist monks.
>> The Nanometi [phonetic]?
>> Yeah, and this was probably
1995 or so that I went over there,
pretty early on in all
the hub all about it
after it was revealed
that this had happened.
And it was a great day, you know.
And those are some of the
moments that, you know,
where research really just comes
alive and is vital, you know,
and just sitting with these
women and seeing their faces
and seeing all their
differences, you know,
that they were individuals.
You know, they're not
just all victims, right?
And things were perpetrated on them,
but they had all this
different histories.
And you know psychologies.
And that was very instructive.
You know, I had to remember
that I wasn't writing history.
You know, I'm writing a novel,
which is entirely a different thing.
And I think that's why
novels are important still.
I hope. I mean, you know,
history is one thing,
and it's important to know.
But a novel can give you
an intimate secret history
that maybe no one wants to look
at and that isn't always so patent
or black and white,
maybe isn't even all
that glorious, but it's very human.
>> Is it on?
How do you manage when you're
writing about war and children dying
and things that are very difficult.
How do you manage everyday to go
back and forth between the world
that you're creating that's so sad
and tragic and then, I don't know,
taking your kids to soccer
practice or something like that.
>> That's a good question, you
know, sometimes it was hard.
You know, sometimes you need
something called Pinot noir.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Sometimes.
But you know, it is kinda hard.
This, you know, this book,
unlike my previous three,
I did have a little bit
of difficulty transitioning
back and forth.
You know, I'd come
downstairs and my life with--
I was just sort of sit there, and
my wife would say, "What happened?"
I'll say, I don't know
what happened.
I can't, you know, I just,
I don't know what happened.
So--
>> Does it make it difficult
in the morning sometimes
to go back to that world?
>> Yeah, every morning, I
tell you, every morning is,
and I remember reading
this about John Updike,
he said that every morning
he looked at the paper
and make all these excuses
why he wouldn't go upstairs,
and I know exactly
that feeling, you know,
I read every word of the paper.
[ Laughter ]
>> Because it, you know, 'cause
you know you're gonna like get
into stuff and that not just-- not
that it's just difficult or unhappy
or sad, but that you kinda have
to really work it, you know.
It's so frustrating sometimes.
Thank you for your question.
>> Do you feel like you've been
labeled as an Asian-American author
and all these restrict what
your subject matter will be
and what you can write about?
>> Well, I don't think it--
it doesn't restrict me.
I think I hope one of things I
worry about is that, one, you know,
say one of you would see
my name on this book, say,
and just naturally think that's sort
of a foreign name,
and I don't, you know.
Not that your races do anything, but
that you might just literally say,
you know what, it doesn't
speak to me in this certain,
I don't know way, and
that you might assume also
that it's really a book only for
Asian-Americans or Korean-Americans.
And you know, that's something
that I absolutely don't--
wouldn't want to have.
I mean I would want Korean-Americans
or Asian-Americans to look
at my work and really be moved
by it and think, yes, you know,
he's connected with something there.
But if a non-Asian person, you know,
were to read my books and think,
you know, I want them to
have the same feelings.
So it's more about reader
expectations than what limits.
I'm not limited because, you
know, I mean that's why I write.
I mean writing is about
liberty in the end.
>> You know, I just want to
say I do feel bonded to you
by your name and by your ethnicity.
>> Thank you.
>> I love to read books
about people who come
from different cultures
and countries.
And I've read a great many
by Chinese-American writers
but there haven't been very
many of the Korean-Americans.
Except for--
>> Actually there have been.
>> Well, that I'm not aware of.
There may have been some
that are not as well known.
So, I just wanted to say, I'm
very happy that you're writing
because I'm interested in learning
more about the Korean culture.
There's also a new book out called
"The Calligrapher's Daughter"
by Eugenia Kim, and that gives
another picture of life growing
up in Korea that was
very interesting.
>> Alright.
Thank you.
Okay. Well, thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.